how's it going everybody I have an
Avengers 4 trailer update for you we
really haven't gotten anything about the
trailer except for Kevin Feige telling
us that it's going to come out before
the end of the year so that helped it
narrowed it down a little bit but it
seems like now we can narrow it down a
little bit more also my giveaway
continues I'm picking a new winner
tomorrow which is Saturday if you would
like to enter for your chance to win a
copy of infinity war Deadpool 2 or
ant-man and the wasp on blu-ray and some
special edition posters all you have to
do is subscribe to my channel like the
video and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero and
after this giveaway I'll be starting a
new one so the Captain Marvel prelude
came out a couple of days ago it was
really good and it let you know what
director fury and agent Hill were doing
during the events of Civil War and of
course it talked about Captain Marvel
but what was the most interesting is
that at the end there was actually an ad
for the Avengers for prelude now it just
says Avengers because of course we don't
have a title yet but this Prelude comes
out December 5th and here's the thing
the preludes always come out after the
trailers come out key example we just
got the Captain Marvel Prelude but we
got the Captain Marvel trailer already
when the infinity war preludes part 1
and part 2 came out we already had
multiple trailers for infinity war so
you can see what Marvel does here they
released the preludes after the trailers
have already been released and we don't
have an Avengers 4 trailer yet but we do
have a release date for the Avengers 4
prelude which means we should get the
first trailer for Avengers 4 before
December 5th
that's only 19 days away but we should
actually get it before December 5th a
lot of people are saying November 29th
because that's the one-year mark for the
first infinity war trailer so that could
very well be when we finally get the
first trailer for Avengers 4 along with
the title but based on what Marvel has
done over and over again we should get
the trailer within the next 19 days
before December 5th so let me know what
you all think about this and let me know
which day you think the trailer is
actually going to drop on whether it be
Thanksgiving during a football game or
the 29th let me know your thoughts in
the comments below and again I'm picking
a new giveaway winner on Saturday all
you have to do to enter for your chance
to win is subscribe
my channel like the video and comment
down below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero as always thank you
all so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]